التي تقع في محيط
مستوطنه
نحو المناطق الشرقيه من قطاع غزه هذه
المنطقه التي نتحدث عنها الان والتي اصيب
فيها شخصان وفقا ما اعلنت وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه قبل قليل ونحن نتحدث بطبيعه
الحال عن حوالي
12 الى 15 كيلو مترا في هذه النقطه في
المنطقه الشماليه من مستوطنه التي تقع في
مجمع مستوطنات شعرها في المنطقه الشماليه
الشرقيه من قطاع غزه لدى يضم عدد كبير من
المستوطنات ابرزها
في المنطقه الشماليه الشرقيه من قطاع غزه
والتي شهدت اطلاق قذائف صاروخيه عديده من
القطاع باتجاه هذه الاماكن وابرزها بطبيعه
الحال اصدارات التي تلقت العدد الاكبر من
هذه القذافه الصاروخيه ولكن المشهد لم
يتوقف عند بطبيعه الحال في هذه الصوره
يمكن القول بان القذائف الصاروخيه
الفلسطينيه تركز اليوم في اسدود عسقلان
ومناطق غلاف غزه لتكون دائره النار
الفلسطينيه من اسدود شمالا الى اشكول
جنوبا وهذه المنطقه التي نتحدث عنها حوالي
30 كيلومتر شمال الحدود بين قطاع غزه
واسرائيل اشدود وعسقلان اسدود بطبيعه
الحال المنطقه المهمه للغايه بالنسبه
لاسرائيل وايضا عسقلان التي تضم منطقه
الصناعيه المهمه للغايه في المنطقه الوسطى
من اسرائيل عندما نتحدث عن المستوطنات
داخل او في محيط غلاف غزه فنحن نتحدث كما
ذكرنا قبل قليل عن هذه المناطق من زكيم
شمالا حيث يقف مراسلنا الياس كرام الى
وهذه المنطقه هذا المجمع مستوطنات كيسوفيم
واشكول قبل قليل اعلنت القوات الاحتلال او
السلطات الاسرائيليه عن دعوه لحظر التجول
او عدم مغادره الاسرائيليين لهذه المناطق
المناطق التي حددتها السلطات الاسرائيليه
بالدعوه لعدم الخروج من المنازل المناطق
الشماليه الشرقيه من قطاع غزه وتحديدا
اكثر هذه المستوطنات
مثل السيم هذه المستوطنات الثلاث التي تضم
عددا من المستوطنين في هذه المنطقه قالت
سلطات الاحتلال او سلطات الاسرائيليه انها
تنصح سكان هذه المناطق بعدم التحرك من
المنازل عندما نتحدث عن هذه المناطق فنحن
نتحدث عن اقل من سته كيلومترات فقط بين
حنون في شمال قطاع غزه اقل من ثلاثه كيلو
متر بين مثل السيم وداخل قطاع غزه وايضا
المسافه ذاتها بالنسبه لايفيم لماذا هذا
الخبر
لماذا هذا الخبر مهم لكن يبدو ان هناك
تطورات مهمه الان نعود الى عبد القادر
وسنعود بطبيعه الحال لشرح هذه التفاصيل
بشكل اكبر في سياق هذه